we make do we figure it out and I feel
like I've kind of figured out what works
for us Kristin Cavallari and Jay Cutler
are going their separate ways after 10
years and three kids together
the former Laguna Beach star announced
the news on Instagram on Sunday Kristin
posted this picture of her and Jay
writing with great sadness after 10
years together we have come to a loving
conclusion to get a divorce we have
nothing but love and respect for one
another and are deeply grateful for the
years shared memories made and the
children we are so proud of my kids my
family they're my number one priority
they always will be the reality star
says her and Jay have grown apart and
asked for privacy as they navigate this
difficult time
additionally the former NFL player
shared the same statement on his
Instagram with this black-and-white
picture the pair tied the knot in 2013
in Nashville after dating on and off for
years they would have celebrated their
wedding anniversary in just two months
it's been interesting we've really
completely shifted roles so it's just
been trying to like navigate this new
normal
Kristin has been very open about the
shift in her marriage since Jay left the
NFL after the 2017 season he's 35 he's
only ever known football he doesn't
really know what he wants to do but he's
35 he's gonna figure something out he'll
do something and I don't want to badger
him and push him and push him I'm
working and he's able to be Holmes which
has been an issue Kristin and Jo 'pn DUP
about the relationship problems on her
TV show very Cavallari when you're
playing football like literally I had to
give up my whole life and I had to just
live your life and I never gave you a
hard time about it like it just was what
it was and I was at every game and I
supported you and I did everything that
I was supposed to do as a wife and I
feel like since I've gotten really busy
I just haven't I don't feel that same
support from you at one point Kristin
said their marriage is not what it seems
when the outside like things are so
perfect and things are so great but
actually like they're not and that's
something the uncommon James founder
even had some rocky moments with her
best friend Kelly after cheating rumors
swirled between her and Jay it takes me
a while to trust people and I don't
always know what people's motives
I guess it just says what it is but it
hurts et spoke to Kristen back in 2018
where she expressed how her TV show has
affected their marriage before we start
shooting season 1 we were very adamant
about like okay this is what we're
willing to put out there this is what
we're not and we just always talk about
it so that we're both really comfortable
think - for me like I know this world
I've done it for so many years this is
all very new for him so I just always
want to make sure he's comfortable and
he's cool with everything that's
happening but you know I wouldn't say
it's been good or bad for our
relationship
you